hey there townscapers and welcome back
to my channel if this is your first time
here i want to give you a big welcome
and i want to thank you so much for
coming by today
please do me a favor and hit the like
button share this video with other
people that you think may enjoy the
content
it'll help me out a lot and i really
appreciate it also make sure you hit the
subscribe button and hit the
notification bell so that way you don't
miss anything that i upload
um today i want to show you the tour for
chapter five of connecting small towns
i'll start uploading chapter six later
this week but i hope you all enjoyed
chapter five it was one of those bills
where i got distracted and i kind of
just filled in the whole grid
got lost in the in the flow of things um
but i just want to thank you all for
coming by and showing me some love this
week i really really appreciate it i was
checking out my stats and i'm over 10
000 views and that's just really amazing
to me
i wouldn't be able to do this without
you so i really appreciate it you guys
just keep doing what you're doing and
i'll keep providing content for you to
enjoy um so thank you again i just can't
stress that enough um
also if you enjoy my work and you're
looking for other ways to support me for
free
you can do so by clicking on the links
down in the description below
one link will simply take you back to my
home page another way that you can
support me is you can view me on the
brave browser um if you have the brave
browser all you have to do is just open
my channel on the browser and view my
videos that way and that will help me
out i get support that way
if you don't have brave the link is also
in the description all you have to do is
click on the link it will take you to
the download page it will prompt you to
download and i would really appreciate
it you guys
if you haven't seen chapter 5 or you
just want to view it again the video
will
be linked in the card in the upper right
corner of this video i'm along with some
other cards so
please be sure to check those out as
well as there's some good stuff in there
if you do like the content please hit
the like button subscribe and share with
your fellow youtube friends uh it would
really help me out a lot and i really
really appreciate
it but anyways that's all for me please
enjoy the video thank you for viewing
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey there townscaper if you're hearing
this and that means you made it to the
end i just want to thank you so much for
viewing it's greatly appreciated make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
make sure you hit that like button
because that will help me out a lot
also you can follow me on instagram and
twitter the links are down in the
description below
and again i just want to say thank you
so much for checking in and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you